Dieser Podcast wird Ihnen von der LMU
München zur Verfügung gestellt. Gerne wieder.
Ich werde dieses zweite Top von Professor Brandon öffnen.
Er wird seine Lektüre
über Hagars Einführung fortsetzen und heute
wird der zweite Teil seines Vortrags die
Titeldarstellung und die Erfahrung
des Fehlers sein  Die funktionalistische Herangehensweise an
die Unterscheidung zwischen Schein und
Wirklichkeit.
Danke, es ist eine hartnäckige Gruppe,
die nach der ersten Vorlesung zurückkam. Ich
schätze, dass meine heutige Vorlesung in zwei
Teilen besteht. Erstens möchte ich über
Strategie sprechen und in der zweiten Hälfte werde ich
sprechen  Darüber, wie Hangul meiner Meinung nach
diese Strategie umsetzt, begann ich meinen vorherigen
Vortrag mit der Formulierung eines zentralen
Kriteriums der Angemessenheit für Theorien mit
konzeptionellem Inhalt, das Hagel
zufolge durch die entscheidende Rolle geschaffen wird, die
diese Theorien in
Wissenstheorien spielen, mit denen er seine Einführung beginnt
Phänomenologie, indem sie darauf besteht, dass unsere
semantische Theorie uns nicht bereits
zu erkenntnistheoretischem Skeptizismus verurteilen darf unser
Verständnis von Diskursiv  Die
Zufriedenheit muss zumindest die Möglichkeit offen lassen
, dass wir durch das
Eingehen konzeptionell inhaltsvoller Verpflichtungen
in einigen Fällen, wenn alles gut geht
, erfahren können, wie die Dinge wirklich
sind, dann argumentiert er, dass diese
Bedingung von keinem Konto erfüllt werden kann, das
eine Kluft aufreißt  der Verständlichkeit, die trennt,
wie die Dinge uns subjektiv erscheinen, wie
sie für das Bewusstsein sind, und wie sie
objektiv an sich
sind. Seit Descartes haben moderne erkenntnistheoretische Theorien
verstanden, dass Wissen das Produkt
von zwei Faktoren ist, dem Gras des Wissenden
subjektiver Gedanken und der
repräsentativen Beziehungen dieser Gedanken zu objektiven
Dingen, die wissen  kognitive Relationen zu
den repräsentierten Dingen werden demnach
vermittelt, indem x' von ihnen repräsentiert werden, unter
Androhung eines unendlichen Regresses kann die Relation
zwischen Erkennenden und dort Repräsentierenden von
x' im Allgemeinen nicht als
selbst vermittelt verstanden werden und repräsentational müssen
zumindest einige der Repräsentanten
unmittelbar erfasst werden  im Sinne von
von nicht-gegenständlichen 'i Ich glaube nicht,
dass Hegel
alle erkenntnistheoretischen
Theorien, die diese zweistufige
Darstellungsstruktur aufweisen, als im Prinzip gebrochen zurückweist, obwohl
einige seiner Rhetorik uns dazu einlädt, darüber nachzudenken, dass die
Ablehnung von Theorien dieser
Form kein wesentliches Element ist und
sicherlich nicht dieses
wesentliche Element in der
metakonzeptionellen Revolution vom Denken in
Kategorien mit der Struktur von Fischen hin
zum Denken in
Kategorien mit der Struktur von Fandoms,
die er empfiehlt, sondern Hagel
beginnt die eigentliche Phänomenologie mit der
Behauptung, dass die Zweistufigkeit
Repräsentation der histologischen
Erklärungsstrategie führt unweigerlich zu
skeptischen Schlussfolgerungen, wenn sie
mit einer bestimmten Hilfshypothese
über den Unterschied zwischen
Repräsentation von z' und Repräsentativen
kombiniert wird, die verlockend und in vielerlei Hinsicht
natürlich ist, nämlich die Vorstellung, dass nur die
Repräsentation von x'
Erscheinungsphänomene konzeptionell sind  Form gut, was ist
Die von ihnen repräsentierte Realität Noumenon ist
nun auf so wenigen kognitiven Prozessen,
die nicht-konzeptionelle
Realität in oder auf konzeptionelle
Repräsentationen transformieren oder abbilden müssen, da die
Repräsentationsbeziehungen dieser
Prozesse Institut nicht-konzeptuelle
Repräsentanten mit konzeptuellen Repräsentationen
x in Beziehung setzen,
um dieses Bild in den Blick zu bekommen, nehme ich an
Der Sinn von Hegels Metapher vom
Wissen als Instrument oder Medium in
den einleitenden Absätzen der
Einleitung ist der Schuldige der semantischen
Annahme, die die erkenntnistheoretische Skepsis zu erzwingen droht,
indem sie
eine Kluft der Verständlichkeit zwischen dem
Denken und der gedachten Welt aushebt, ist
die Idee, dass nur was  wir denken und nicht
die Welt, die wir denken, ist begrifflich
artikuliert Der konstruktive Vorschlag
, den Hegel als Alternative zu
dieser Annahme anbietet, ist eine radikal neue nicht-
psychologische Konzeption des
Begrifflichen, nach dieser
Auffassung begrifflich inhaltsvoll zu sein
, in materiellen Relationen zu stehen
Einkommen  patibility
Er sagt bestimmte Negation und
materielle Konsequenz Er sagt Mediation
zu anderen solchen Inhaltselementen Ich nenne dies
eine nicht-psychologische Konzeption des
Konzeptuellen, weil es
von der Betrachtung der Prozesse oder
Praktiken der Anwendung von Konzepten in
Urteilen und absichtlichen Handlungen
objektiver Sachverhalte losgelöst werden kann  und
Eigenschaften
in Relationen
materieller Inkompatibilität und Konsequenz zueinander stehen
und dementsprechend verständlich sind, ist
bereits in begrifflicher Form, ganz abgesehen
von etwaigen Relationen, in denen sie
zu den kognitiven und praktischen
Aktivitäten des Erkennens und Handelns von
Subjekten tatsächlich objektiver
Sachverhalte und Sachverhalte stehen mögen  Eigenschaften, die
in solchen Beziehungen nicht zueinander stünden, wären sie
weder verständlich noch
determinierbar, dann könnten wir keinen
Sinn für die Idee haben, dass es eine
bestimmte Art gibt, wie die Welt tatsächlich ist,
denn diese Idee beinhaltet im Wesentlichen den
Gegensatz zu anderen  Möglichkeiten, wie die Welt
anders sein könnte  Die Verbindungen, die Objekte haben
könnten, und die Kontraste, aufgrund
derer Sachverhalte und
Eigenschaften bestimmt werden, müssen sowohl mäßig
exklusive Unterschiede als auch bloße
Unterschiede beinhalten, Unterschiede wie es
unmöglich ist, dass ein Stück reines Kupfer
bei Temperaturen über
tausendachtzig Grad fest bleibt.  fünf grad c nicht nur
rot und quadratisch sind unterschiedliche, sondern
kompatible eigenschaften diese nicht
psychologische konzeption des
begrifflichen wird in der
einleitung selbst nicht weiter ausgeführt, sondern ist das
hauptthema der folgenden
kapitel zum bewusstsein ich habe es dennoch
in meiner ersten vorlesung besprochen, weil
es wichtig ist  Verstehen Sie, wie Hegel
vorschlägt, die Gefahr zu vermeiden,
eine Kluft der Verständlichkeit
auszuheben, die subjektive konzeptionelle
Repräsentation von objektiven nicht-
konzeptuellen Repräsentanten trennt. Es ist die Gefahr,
eine solche Kluft auszuheben, und die
semantische Repräsentationstheorie, die
er sieht, ist potenziell tödlich für das
erkenntnistheoretische Unternehmen, wenn der
Prozess  des Erkennens eine solche Lücke verbringen muss,
dann denkt Hegel, dass die Möglichkeit
echter Erkenntnis Erkenntnis, wie die
Dinge an sich sind, nicht nur, wie
sie für das Bewusstsein sind,
als unverständlicher
begrifflicher Realismus über die
von ihm neu verstandene objektive Welt grundsätzlich ausgeschlossen sein wird  nicht
konzeptionelle Konzeption des
konzeptionellen Hegels alternative Antwort, wie ich es
lese, die Aufgabe der letzten zwei
Drittel der Einleitung besteht darin, eine Denkweise über Repräsentation zu skizzieren,
nachdem
das zweistufige repräsentationale SEM-
Modell von der
anstößigen Nebenverpflichtung befreit wurde
das Verstehen von Repräsentieren als Beziehung zwischen
konzeptionellem Repräsentieren x' und nicht
konzeptionellem Repräsentieren x' bedeutet, zu
zeigen, wie zwei der Schlüsselkriterien
der Angemessenheit erfüllt werden können, die ich
in meinem vorherigen Vortrag identifiziert habe
oder
sogar vorzugeben, eine Repräsentation von etwas zu sein,
repräsentierte eine Erscheinung von etwas  Die
Erfüllung dieser Bedingung besteht darin, zu erklären,
was Repräsentation der
Struktur und Begründung von Hegels
Darstellung von Repräsentationszweck und -erfolg zugrunde liegt, und
wird auch Licht auf die
zweite Desiderata werfen, die rationale
Einschränkungsbedingung, die die RCC verlangt,
dass wir erklären, wie das
Bewusstsein wissender Subjekte spricht oder
denkt  über das Repräsentierte begründen kann
, was sie darüber sagen oder
denken
Die Darstellung der Repräsentation, die
Hegel in der Einleitung skizziert, und
wie sie vorschlägt, diese Bedingungen zu erfüllen
, ist die Aufgabe, die ich in diesem
Vortrag jetzt unserem gewöhnlichen
vorsystematischen nichttheoretischen Denken übernehme  sprechen über
denken und sprechen unterscheidet
zwischen dem, was wir denken oder sagen
einerseits und dem, worüber wir denken oder
sprechen andererseits, so können wir
dementsprechend sagen, dass intentionalität die
inhaltsfülle des denkens und sprechens
zwei dimensionen hat, was wir wann ausdrücken  wir
sagen oder denken etwas und was wir
darstellen, tun  Wir können also sagen, dass sowohl
Kant zu der Überzeugung kam, dass Lumple
ihn verriet, als auch Kant glaubte, dass sein
treuer Diener Kant verriet,
im ersten den
Aussagesatz, der dem folgt,
der den Inhalt der Überzeugung ausdrückt, und
im zweiten die Nominalphrase  im
rahmen der von sagt, was der glaube
über das, was ich hegels
nichtpsychologische konzeption des
begrifflichen genannt habe, die begriffliche
inhaltsfülle darin besteht, in
materiell unvereinbaren verhältnissen zu stehen, ist
folglich ein modell dessen, was man
sagt oder denkt  erste Dimension der
Intentionalität oder Inhaltsfülle, was
wir diese Intentionalität nennen könnten
, deshalb nenne ich dies die
konzeptionelle Dimension der Intentionalität
, die Frage, die jetzt auf dem
Tisch liegt, ist, wie er die andere Repräsentationsdimension versteht, die
wir
Intentionalität nennen könnten  die
empiristen hatten eine
erklärungsordnung verfolgt, die mit dem
gegenständlichen conte beginnt  nt Fülle und
versucht tatsächlich
, begriffliche Inhaltsfülle
allgemeiner in Begriffen davon zu verstehen und zu erklären, und wir sehen diese
Art der Erklärung in unseren eigenen
Tagen, wie ich ihn verstehe, verfolgt Hegel eine
ergänzende Erklärungsordnung, die das
Projekt ist, das er in der
Einleitung umreißt  Um den Begriff der
Repräsentation anhand seines
nichtpsychologischen Konzepts der konzeptuellen
Inhaltsfülle
zu erläutern, möchte ich im Folgenden erklären, wie ich seine Strategie verstehe,
diese konzeptualistische
Erklärungsordnung für eine der wichtigsten
Lektionen zu verfolgen, die wir meiner Meinung nach von Hegel lernen sollten
denn unser heutiges Denken betrifft
seine Ausarbeitung einer Alternative zum
repräsentationalen
Erklärungsspeicher für die beiden Dimensionen der
Intentionalität, die die
philosophische Semantik der
philosophischen Tradition des vergangenen
Jahrhunderts dominiert hat, die wir ebenso
wie die philosophische Tradition
Hegels erben  geerbt Hegel hat eine große neue Idee,
wie man repr erklärt  Bedeutungsinhalt
in Begriffen von konzeptuellen Inhalten,
die nicht psychologisch verstanden werden, wie er
es in Bezug auf die Artikulation durch
Beziehungen materieller Inkompatibilität
und Konsequenz tut, die Art und Weise, wie er diese konzeptualistische Idee ausfüllt, lässt
sich am besten als
eine Möglichkeit verstehen
, zwei Inhaltsideen zu kombinieren und gemeinsam zu entwickeln, wobei die
erste konstant ist  Was Urteile
von den Reaktionen bloß natürlicher
Wesen unterscheidet, ist, dass wir in besonderer
Weise für unsere Arbeit verantwortlich sind,
sobald sie Verpflichtungen von Stunden zum Ausdruck bringen
Befürwortung Autorität dies sind alles
normative Konzepte Conte versteht
Konzepte als das, was er
Urteilsfunktionen in dem Sinne nennt, dass die
in Urteilen angewandten Konzepte bestimmen, wofür
sich das Subjekt verantwortlich gemacht hat, wozu es
sich verpflichtet hat
oder mit seiner Autorität bei der Beurteilung von
Subjekten normativ bindend ausgestattet ist  Themen  Elfen durch
Regeln, das heißt Konzepte, die
die Art und das Ausmaß ihres
Engagements bestimmen, indem sie eine Rechnung mit
dieser Form verfolgen, stellt Khan dringend die
Frage, wie die normative Bindung zu verstehen ist, die
sein Verb in der
Länge der in
der frühen Neuzeit verwendeten Konzepte bei der Beurteilung gut verfehlt  Tradition
beginnend mit Descartes hatte sich Sorgen
um unseren Zugriff auf Konzepte gemacht, für Kant wird das
Problem, ihren
normativen Zugriff auf uns zu verstehen, was es ist, sich zu
verpflichten oder für den Anspruch verantwortlich zu sein, der
die zweite inhaltliche Idee bezahlt,
auf der Hegels konzeptioneller Ansatz
zur Repräsentationsdimension basiert
Intentionalität beruht darauf, dass die
betreffende Verantwortung
als eine Art Aufgabenverantwortung verstanden werden soll.
Es ist die Verantwortung
, etwas zu tun, wofür man
verantwortlich ist, indem man sich zur Zahlung verpflichtet, indem
man die neue Verpflichtung
in die Konstellation früherer
Verpflichtungen integriert, um sie zu übernehmen  seine
Darstellung der Art von Einheit aufrechterhalten, die
für ap charakteristisch ist  erzeption eine wahrnehmung
ist ein kognitives oder einsichtiges bewusstsein ein
bewusstsein, das
bei der wahrnehmung auf wissen hinauslaufen kann, ist für kant ein urteilen ein
urteil ist die form einer wahrnehmung
weil urteile die kleinste einheit sind,
für die man kognitive verantwortung übernehmen kann
diese integration ist eine
art der gattung conte
Synthese, weshalb die
fragliche strukturelle Einheit eine synthetische
Einheit einer Wahrnehmung ist,
diese integrative Aufgabe,
Verantwortung hat drei Dimensionen,
kritische Amplitude und Rechtfertigung,
dies sind Arten rationaler
Verpflichtungen, denn sie werden artikuliert, durch
die Verpflichtungen als Gründe dafür
und dagegen dienen  Die andere wichtige
Verantwortung für die integrative synthetische Aufgabe besteht darin,
Verpflichtungen abzulehnen, die
mit anderen Verpflichtungen materiell unvereinbar
sind. Sobald AmpliTube
die
Verantwortung für die integrative synthetische Aufgabe darin besteht,
Verpflichtungen anzuerkennen, die materielle
Folgen anderer Verpflichtungen sind, die
man anerkannt hat, und solche, die gerecht sind  ein Sieg
integrative synthetische Aufgabe
Verantwortung ist, Gründe für die Verpflichtungen liefern zu können, die
man
anerkennt, indem man andere
Verpflichtungen setzt, die man anerkennt, von denen
sie materielle Konsequenzen sind
, die z' zu tun sind, die den
Auto-B's entsprechen
, die den eigenen kognitiven Verpflichtungen,
Urteilen oder entsprechen  Überzeugungen sollten
konsequent vollständig sein und ihre Rationalitätsnormen rechtfertigen,
wenn sie explizit
anerkannt werden, dass sie die Normen
inhaltlicher Systematik sind, denn Urteilen
besteht darin, sich implizit zu verpflichten
, die kritische
AmpliTube und nur scheinbare Aufgabe zu erfüllen
integrative Aufgaben integrative synthetische
Aufgabe Verantwortlichkeiten bei der Beurteilung
überhaupt  übernimmt implizit die rationalen
systematischen Verpflichtungen zusammen
definieren sie die rationale normative synthetische
Einheit einer
Wahrnehmung  sich selbst zu urteilen, dass
P die rationale Artikulation der
normativen synthetischen integrativen Aufgabe
Verantwortung Inhalt Phi's als eine
Art Befürwortung des Urteilens
bedeutet, dass wir Richterinhalte
in Bezug auf das verstehen können, was wir tun, wenn wir
für diese Inhalte urteilen
müssen die rationalen Beziehungen wie
Richter' Balcon Zelte zueinander bestimmen,
was ein Grund für und gegen was die
kritischen integrativen synthetischen Aufgaben sind
,
die der Richter aller Inhalte verlangt, stehen
zueinander in Beziehungen materieller
Unverträglichkeit der Amplitude und nur
obligatorisch integrativ  Synthetische Aufgaben
Verantwortlichkeiten verlangen, dass der Richterwille
Inhalt in materiellen Folgebeziehungen zueinander steht,
und
das heißt, die Richterwillensinhalte
müssen Begriffsinhalt in dem
Sinne haben, den Hegel selbst befürwortet, so
dass der Begriff des Begrifflichen Hegel
bereits implizit in der Folge sieht
Bericht über die Beurteilung von Hegel extrahiert seine
conceptio  n der begrifflichen
Inhaltsfülle von dem, was erforderlich ist,
um eine Konstellation von Bindungen zu synthetisieren, die
die rationale
normative Einheit aufweisen, um eine
Wahrnehmung zu begründen, ist dies eine weitgehend
funktionalistische Idee, da sie die Idee des
Verständnisses von Urteilen über Inhalte in
Bezug auf die Rolle des Urteilens im
integrativen Prozess versteht  sich mit der
Wahrnehmung dieser funktionalistischen
Erklärungsstrategie zu begnügen, ist von erster
Bedeutung, um nicht nur
Hegels Begriffskonzeption der
Ausdrucksdimension der
Intentionalität zu verstehen, sondern auch die darauf
aufbauende Darstellung
der Repräsentationsdimension der
Intentionalität des Funktionalen
rekonstruiert im Hinblick auf die Rolle in der
Synthese einer Wahrnehmung ist natürlich
höchstens Teil von Kant's Verständnis
des Begrifflichen, denn dieser abstrakte
Top-down-Ansatz zu Begriffen hängt nicht
wesentlich von ihrem Kontrast
zu und ihrer Zusammenarbeit mit Intuitionen ab, auf die
Cotto selbst bestehen würde  Dies ist der
Grund  Begriffe ausschließlich im
Hinblick auf Beziehungen materieller
Inkompatibilität und Folgen zu verstehen, abgesehen
von jeder Beziehung zu Intuitionen,
muss rein formal sein, so dass konzipierte
Begriffe leer im Sinne von
ohne Repräsentationsgehalt wären,
aber aus der Sicht von Hegels
konzeptioneller Erklärung  Strategie liefert diese
Konzeption der expressiven oder
konzeptuellen Dimension der
Intentionalität tatsächlich das Rohmaterial,
aus dem heraus die darstellende
Dimension zu verstehen ist.
Hegel sieht, dass Inhalt
nicht nur der
expressiven konzeptuellen Dimension der
Intentionalität eine normative Annäherung entgegensetzt, sondern de dicto diese
Intentionalität  aber auch zur
Repräsentationsdimension DeRay der
Intentionalität ist der konzeptionelle Inhalt
eines Urteils das, wofür man sich
beim Urteilen verantwortlich macht, und sein
Repräsentationsgehalt,
was durch es repräsentiert wird, ist das, wofür
man sich verantwortlich macht
antwortet
Für ein Urteil in der Hinsicht, dass P darin
besteht, dafür verantwortlich zu sein
, es in die Konstellation der
eigenen früheren Verpflichtungen zu integrieren, unterstützte SOSUS
die rationale normative Einheit,
die für eine Wahrnehmung charakteristisch ist, was das
Urteil darüber ist, was durch
es repräsentiert wird, übt eine unverwechselbare Art
von Autorität aus  über Beurteilungen seiner
Richtigkeit, wie man sagen möchte, ein
Vorstellen des
Dargestellten Paradigmatisch ist ein Urteilen
als Vorstellen
nur insofern verständlich, als es für seine
Richtigkeit zu etwas verantwortlich ist, das dabei
von ihm in Kant
's objektiver Form des Urteils vertreten wird  ist das, was
er das Objekt gleich x nennt, das jedes
Urteil als solches für
seine Richtigkeit verantwortlich ist, die subjektive Form des
Urteils, das ich denke, das jedes Urteil begleiten kann,
markiert den Wissenden,
der für das Urteil verantwortlich ist, der dafür
verantwortlich ist, es mit den
anderen zu integrieren  für die dieser Wissende die
gleiche Art von r nimmt  Verantwortlichkeit in der Form,
in der dieser Gedanke in Hegels
Einleitung vorkommt Repräsentierte Objekte sind das,
was als normativer Maßstab
Moskaus für Bewertungen von Verbindlichkeiten dient
, die
gerade aufgrund dieser Konstellation von
Autorität und Verantwortung zählen, die Repräsentation dieser Objekte
gilt Hegels große neue Idee
funktionalistische Erklärungsstrategie, die
auf die normative Rolle in der
synthetischen integrativen Tätigkeit des
Urteilens für das Verständnis der konzeptionellen
Dimension von Richterabul-Inhalten auch
für das Verständnis der
repräsentativen Dimension von Inhalten
abzielt, dh er sieht darauf, was wissende
Subjekte tun müssen, um damit zu
zählen  als Anerkennung der Autorität von
etwas, um als Maßstab für die
Beurteilung der Richtigkeit eines Urteils
zu dienen, um Repräsentationsbeziehungen zu verstehen,
wenn er jenes
Tun als einen Aspekt der synthetischen
integrativen Aktivität aufweisen kann, in Bezug auf die
die begriffliche Dimension des Inhalts ist
erklärte h  Er wird die konzeptualistische Erklärungsstrategie durchgeführt haben,
die repräsentationale
Dimension der Intentionalität im Hinblick auf
die expressive konzeptionelle Dimension zu verstehen, er
wird eine funktionalistische
Erklärung der Intentionalität im
Hinblick auf diese Intentionalität gegeben haben, die ich für
die Hauptaufgabe der letzten zwei
Drittel halte  der einführung in die
phänomenologie ist es, diese art der
erarbeitung der konzeptionellen
erklärungsstrategie zum verständnis
der beziehungen zwischen den beiden dimensionen
der intentionalität zu skizzieren der logische fluss, wie ich ihn
sehe, besteht aus sieben schritten
sieht
Beurteilen darin, sich
zu verpflichten, Verantwortung für einige
beurteilbare Inhalte zu übernehmen. Zweitens wird diese
Idee durch die Inhaltsauffassung des
Beurteilens konkretisiert, indem eine neue Verpflichtung
in eine Konstellation früherer
Verpflichtungen integriert wird, um die
rationale normative Einheit mit dem Status von a aufrechtzuerhalten
Wahrnehmung  Drittens wird diese Idee
ausgefüllt durch das Verständnis der synthetischen
integrativen Aktivität als eine
dreigliedrige Struktur von zufrieden stellenden
kritischen AmpliTube und nur offiziellen
-- Viertens mit dieser Idee verbunden ist
die funktionalistische Strategie des
Verstehens von Urteilen über Inhalte, wie
sie durch die Beziehungen artikuliert werden, die sie artikulieren
einspringen müssen, um ihre Rolle in
dieser Aktivität als das zu spielen, was man befürwortet
, sich zu verpflichten oder
im Lichte der dreigliedrigen
Struktur der Synthese einer
Konstellation von Verpflichtungen,
die die rationale Einheit aufweisen, die für eine
absichtsvolle Wahrnehmung charakteristisch ist, zu reagieren
Dieser Gedanke führt zu einer Vorstellung von
Judge Bowl-Inhalten, wie sie durch
rationale Beziehungen materieller
Inkompatibilität artikuliert werden, die von den
kritischen Aufgabenverantwortungen und
materiellen Konsequenzen angesprochen werden, auf die sich die
AmpliTube bezieht, und rechtfertigen niedliche ori-Aufgabenverantwortungen.
Das Ergebnis ist Hegels Vorstellung von
konzeptueller Inhaltsfülle in Begriffen  von
bestimmen  ate negation and mediation Die
Strategie zur Umsetzung der
konzeptualistischen Erklärungsordnung besteht darin
, diese Darstellung der expressiven
konzeptuellen Dimension von Intentionalität
sowohl als Rohmaterial
als auch als Modell für eine Darstellung
der repräsentationalen Dimension von
Intentionalität und des konzeptuellen Inhalts, also
Sex, zu behandeln  neben konstanter normativer
Urteilsauffassung wird eine normative
Vorstellung von Repräsentation
unterschieden ein Urteil gilt als
Repräsentant eines repräsentierten Objekts,
insofern es diesem
Objekt für seine Richtigkeit verantwortlich ist, sofern
dieses Objekt Autorität über seine Richtigkeit ausübt oder
als Maßstab für die Beurteilung
seiner Richtigkeit dient 7. und  schließlich besteht die
Strategie darin, die
funktionalistische Idee erneut anzuwenden, um
Repräsentationsinhalte im Hinblick darauf zu verstehen,
was erforderlich ist, um als normativer
Standard für die Beurteilung der
Richtigkeit von Urteilen als Aspekt
des synthetischen Prozesses der Integration
dieser Verpflichtungen in Nachteile zu dienen  Erzählungen
vorausgehender Verpflichtungen, die die
rationale Einheit aufweisen, die für eine Wahrnehmung charakteristisch ist. Nun
, das ist meine Darstellung der Hegelschen Erklärungsstrategie, die meiner Meinung nach
in den letzten zwei Dritteln der Einleitung im Spiel ist.
Jetzt möchte ich darüber sprechen,
wie er das umsetzt, wie er
tatsächlich erzählt  Eine Geschichte, die
diese strategische Planaufgabe erfüllt,
der
Repräsentationsdimension der
Intentionalität gemäß der
konzeptualistischen funktionalistischen Strategie einen Sinn
zu geben, erklärt, was es bedeutet, dass ein
beurteilbarer konzeptioneller Inhalt, der durch
seine Beziehungen materieller
Inkompatibilität und Konsequenz zu anderen
solchen Inhalten artikuliert wird, funktioniert
einen weltlichen
Sachverhalt zu vertreten, zu sagen, welche Rolle in dem
synthetischen integrativen Prozess der Beurteilung
ein Richter allen Inhalts spielen muss,
um als vorgebend zu gelten
, etwas zu vertreten, erfüllt dann das,
was ich in meinem ersten Vortrag die
Art der Darstellungsbedingung des NPC genannt habe
es sagt, was es ist, zu sein oder zu
pu  rport eine Darstellungsweise von
etwas anderem zu sein
eine Darstellung von etwas Repräsentiertem
Hegels bevorzugter Art, über
das zu sprechen, was ich Repräsentation x' genannt habe, ist was die
Dinge für das Bewusstsein sind was die
Dinge für das Bewusstsein sind vorgibt, die
Erscheinung einer Realität zu sein was die Dinge  sind
an sich befriedigend der npc
sagt, was es ist, wenn sich etwas
zeigt, hat eine Erscheinung von etwas, die
repräsentierende, repräsentierte Erscheinung,
Realität, was die Dinge für das
Bewusstsein sind, was die Dinge an sich sind
, und die Gewissheit, Wahrheit,
Unterscheidungen stimmen auch für Hegel mit
den Contin-Phänomenen überein  Noumenon
Unterscheidung Die Frage, die Hegel stellt,
ist, was es bedeutet, dass etwas
etwas für das Bewusstsein ist. Dies stellt
die tiefste und wichtigste
Frage nach der repräsentativen
Dimension der Intentionalität. Hegel setzt überhaupt nicht
voraus, dass die
Dinge etwas für das Bewusstsein sind, es ist
keines  seiner Primitiven bietet er sich eher
als Sophisti an  katierte funktionalistische
Darstellung von Repräsentationsinhalt und
Repräsentationsinhalt, die
eingebettet in und eine Weiterentwicklung der
funktionalistischen Darstellung von
Propositionsinhalt in Bezug auf die Aktivität des
Beurteilens modelliert ist, die er als implizit in
Consuela-
Seedings ansieht, sind sie Haeckel beantwortet die
Frage, die später gestellt werden würde  als
die Spezifizierung der distinktiven Einheit
des Satzes antwortet er
ganzheitlich im Hinblick auf die Stellung zu
anderen Richter Abell-Inhalten in
Beziehungen materieller
Unvereinbarkeit und materieller Folgen  andere
verstehen die Einheit des Satzes
funktional als synthetische
Einheit einer Konstellation von Bindungen
, die für eine Wahrnehmung charakteristisch ist,
die dynamische Einheit geschaffen und aufrechterhalten wird,
indem neue Bindungen mit alten integriert
werden, die der triadischen systematischen
kritischen Amplitude von inge unterliegen  Die erste der
akuten Aufgaben ist, dass die
Einheit des propositionalen Inhalts so
verstanden werden kann im Sinne der Einheit,
die die rationalen Normen definiert, die das
regeln müssen, was man tut, damit solche
Handlungen als Inhalte des Urteilens gelten,
die
die für die propositionale Eigenschaft charakteristische Einheit aufweisen  ist,
was es bedeutet zu sagen, dass es am Ende, wie
Kahn sagt, in der transzendentalen
Deduktion nur eine Einheit gibt,
letztendlich die synthetische Einheit einer
Wahrnehmung, und die Frage ist, wie Hegel
dieses Modell auf die
repräsentative Dimension der
Intentionalität anwenden kann, die wir gesehen haben  Das erste
Puzzlestück ist die Idee, dass
etwas, das etwas für das
Bewusstsein sein soll, in
normativen Begriffen der unverwechselbaren Art
von Autorität zu verstehen ist, die es über
Bewertungen der Richtigkeit der
Urteile ausübt, das Bewusstsein besteht in
Urteilen muss verantwortlich sein für das, was ist
dargestellt für ihre Richtigkeit, damit
sie verständlich sind, da
sie darstellen, dass es ab ist  Es ist eine Erscheinung
davon, wie Hegel den Punkt ausdrückt,
was mit dargestellt wird, um als normativer
Standard für die Beurteilung zu dienen. Die nächste Frage
ist, wie dieser Gedanke
in einem funktionalistischen Geist operationalisiert werden kann, der
im Sinne dessen verstanden wird,
was man tun muss, um als
Anerkennung zu gelten  jene Autorität
, die die Verantwortung dessen anerkennt, was die
Dinge für das Bewusstsein sind, das
heißt, Urteile darüber zu fällen, was die Dinge an sich sind
, das Bewusstsein selbst
muss ihre Urteile als
Repräsentationen einer Realität betrachten, die über
sie hinaus auf etwas hinweisen soll, auf das
sie für ihre Richtigkeit ansonsten antworten
es wäre nicht so, als ob
ein Bewußtsein mit
seinem Urteil darüber Stellung beziehen würde, wie die Dinge an sich sind, seine Urteile
wären nicht, wie die Dinge für das Bewußtsein wirklich sind,
was wir dann verstehen müssen,
ist der Sinn, in dem sich das Bewußtsein, wie Hegel sagt,
selbst gibt
sein eigenes Standardende Zitat
wie Zitat in welchem Bewusstsein innerhalb seines eige
en Selbst des  als das An sich
oder das Wahre zündet, haben wir den Maßstab, an dem
das Bewusstsein selbst
sein Wissen zu messen vorschlägt
ist für
ihn das an sich, aber das Wissen oder
das Sein des Objekts für das
Bewusstsein ist für ihn
noch ein weiterer Moment
Diese Passage markiert eine absolut entscheidende,
wenn auch selten anerkannte Unterscheidung
zwischen Dingen, die etwas für das
Bewusstsein sind, und Dingen, die etwas
für das Bewusstsein sind. Es ist leicht, diese Unterscheidung zu übersehen,
da im Gegensatz zu den Phrasen
für Bewusstsein für perverses Design an
sich honzik für
Bewusstsein ohne eine explizite
Präposition in der ausgedrückt wird  Dativ-
Konstruktionsteam,
was Hegel uns sagt, ist som  Das
Bewusstsein ist nur eine Unterscheidung
zwischen dem, was die Dinge für das
Bewusstsein sind, und dem, was sie an
sich sind. Ich nehme an, dass das, was
etwas für das Bewusstsein ist, in
erster Linie der Inhalt eines
Urteils ist,
etwas, das
ausdrücklich darin enthalten ist  der Sinn
, denkbar und stata
belen Aussagesätze oder
Klauseln sind propositionale Inhalte, wie wir
gesehen haben, Hegel versteht solche Inhalte im
Sinne von Relationen materieller
Unvereinbarkeit und damit materieller
Konsequenz, in denen sie zueinander stehen,
und wiederum versteht er diese Relationen
im Hinblick auf die Rolle, die beurteilbare
Inhalte im rationalen synthetischen Prozess
der Integration und Berichtigung von
Bindungen spielen, um die für die Wahrnehmung charakteristische Einheit aufrechtzuerhalten, ist das,
was die Dinge für das Bewusstsein sind, eine
funktionale Angelegenheit dessen, wie sie
implizit genommen oder praktisch behandelt
werden  Bewusstsein in dem, was es tut
Bewusstsein Hegel sagt
praktisch unterscheidet zwischen dem, was die
Dinge für es sind, und dem, was sie an sich sind
, zwischen Erscheinung und
Realität, sagt er, ist ihr
Vergleich, wir müssen verstehen, wie das, was das
Bewusstsein tut, wesentlich ist,
um als
Bewusstsein verständlich zu sein, als praktische
Anerkennung dieser Unterscheidung dieses Willens verstanden werden kann
verstehen, wie
z  die synthetische integrative
Aktivität, die die
synthetische Einheit einer Wahrnehmung schafft und aufrechterhält, also muss die
Unterscheidung zwischen Erscheinung und
Realität, was die Dinge für das
Bewusstsein sind, und was sie an
sich darstellen, x' und
Repräsentanten irgendwie
verständlich sein in Bezug auf funktionale
Rollen in Bezug darauf  Tätigkeit,
was Er  gel nennt natürliches Bewusstsein
selbst braucht diese Metabegriffe nicht zu haben
braucht sie nicht
explizit in Urteilen anwenden zu können,
aber wir phänomenologisch
bewussten
Wir, die wir über seine Tätigkeit nachdenken,
müssen dem natürlichen
Bewusstsein ein Verständnis dessen zuschreiben können, was  Diese
Konzepte verdeutlichen ein implizites Verständnis dessen,
was das Bewusstsein tut. Die
normative Auslegung der Repräsentation
lehrt uns, dass die Rolle, die etwas
in der Praxis spielen muss, um
als eine Realität zu funktionieren, die
durch ein Urteil repräsentiert wird oder in einem
Urteil erscheint, die eines normativen
Standards ist  zur Beurteilung ihrer
Richtigkeit sagt uns die von mir im ersten Vortrag
als rationale Zwangsbedingung bezeichnete Bedingung
, dass das, was als
Beurteilungsmaßstab für den Inhalt der Richterschüssel
dient, als Begründung für die Beurteilung dienen können muss, und zwar
ja  muss
dem Bewusstsein zumindest grundsätzlich als Grund
zur Verfügung stehen, um als Grund was zu spielen brauchbar zu sein  s
Die Rolle eines Bewertungsmaßstabs
muss konzeptionell gestaltet sein, er muss dazu geeignet sein
, z und darstellbares
z-- in Relationen materieller
Unvereinbarkeit und Konsequenz darzustellen
, damit er
als Begründung für oder gegen
Urteile eines Maßstabs dienen kann  in Bezug darauf
, ob sie als richtig oder falsch bewertet werden können,
damit kommen wir
zum Kern von Hegels funktionalistischer
Darstellung des Repräsentationszwecks.
Hegels Begriff für den Prozess, durch den
neue Bindungen in eine
Konstellation alter integriert werden, wird
unter dem Aspekt als falsch empfunden  jenes Prozesses, auf
den sich seine Darstellung der
Repräsentationsfunktion des Richters über
Inhalte bezieht, ist der kritische, in
dem Inkompatibilitäten, die sich aus der
Hinzufügung eines neuen Urteils ergeben, anerkannt
und aufgelöst werden. Die systematische normative
Verpflichtung entlang dieser Dimension ist eine
Aufgabe, die Verantwortung
, etwas zu tun  was man
tun muss, ist die synthetische Einheit wiederherzustellen
c  charakteristisch für eine Wahrnehmung durch die
Reparatur der Inkohärenz, die entsteht,
wenn ein Subjekt
unvereinbare Verpflichtungen eingeht. Dieser Prozess ist
die Erfahrung eines Irrtums. Betrachten Sie ein
Beispiel dafür, dass
ein naives Subjekt auf einen Stock blickt, der halb
in das Wasser eines Teichs eingetaucht ist, und
wahrnehmungsmäßig den Glauben erlangt, dass dies der Fall ist
Stock ist verbogen, um ihn herauszuziehen, sie
erwirbt den Glauben, dass er
durchweg gerade ist, sie glaubt, dass er
starr ist und dass das Entfernen aus dem
Wasser seine Form nicht ändert, diese Urteile
sind miteinander unvereinbar, anzuerkennen,
dass anzuerkennen, dass ein
Fehler gemacht wurde, diese Anerkennungen sind
Anerkennung Diese Anerkennungen
sind Anerkennungen der praktischen
Verantwortung zur Wiederherstellung der
Kompatibilität mit den eigenen Verpflichtungen,
dh zur Erfüllung der eigenen kritischen Aufgaben
der Stock ist verbogen
den Glauben aufrechtzuerhalten, dass es gerade ist,
sowie die anderen Nebenverpflichtungen, die
unsere Testperson möglicherweise getroffen hat, als
sie entschied, was sie behalten und
was sie ablehnen sollte, im Lichte ihres
Glaubens, dass sie viel erfahrener
und zuverlässiger darin ist, durchschaute Formen visuell zu beurteilen
Luft oder Wasser als
durch beide bemerken zunächst, dass bei der
Behandlung der Verpflichtung
zur Formgebung zumindest im
Zusammenhang mit Nebenverpflichtungen zu
Starrheit und Formkonstanz das Subjekt sie
implizit so behandelt, als hätten sie ein
gemeinsames Subjekt, als ob es sich um ein und
dasselbe Objekt handelte  denn Verpflichtungen, A
zu biegen und B zu kleben,
sind nicht unvereinbar, nur wenn
es derselbe Stock ist, dem man
diese unvereinbaren
Eigenschaften zuschreibt, sind die daraus resultierenden Richterschaleninhalte
miteinander unvereinbar.
Hegel diskutiert dieses Thema
ausführlich  im Wahrnehmungskapitel
der Phänomenologie, die zwei Verpflichtungen
für unvereinbar hält  Indem man in der
Praxis die Verpflichtung anerkennt,
mindestens eine von ihnen zu revidieren, behandelt man sie so
, als ob sie sich auf ein Objekt
beziehen und ihm kompatibel unvereinbare
Eigenschaften zuschreiben, mit anderen Worten, sie
behandelt sie als Vertreter einer
gemeinsamen Darstellung und
erkennt praktisch die Unvereinbarkeit zweier
Verpflichtungen an  beinhaltet eine Art Repräsentationstriangulation,
indem man sie implizit so behandelt, als ob sie ein Thema teilen, als wäre es
ungefähr dasselbe, zu sagen, dass diese
Anerkennung des gemeinsamen
Repräsentationszwecks implizit ist, bedeutet
zu sagen, dass der Repräsentationszweck
in dem, was das Subjekt tut, anerkannt wird,
anstatt es explizit zu sein
propositionaler Inhalt eines Urteils ein
Urteil dahingehend, dass diese
unterschiedlichen Sinne konzeptionelle Inhalte,
artikuliert durch Relationen materieller
Inkompatibilität und Konsequenz, den gleichen Bezugspunkt auswählen, nämlich,
was diese Bindungen an das Bewusstsein sind,
nicht was sie für das
Bewusstsein sind, das der Stock ist  sowohl gebogen als auch
st  klar für das Bewusstsein, aber die
Inkompatibilität dieser Verpflichtungen ist
im einfachsten Fall nur etwas für das
Bewusstsein. Dies ist ein Punkt über die
erste Phase des Prozesses, der die
Erfahrung der Fehleranerkennung
der materiellen Unvereinbarkeit einiger
Verpflichtungen ist, die das Subjekt in dieser Phase eingegangen ist
die unvereinbaren Verpflichtungen sind
alle auf einer Ebene, auf der noch keine gehässigen
Bewertungen der relativen Autorität oder Glaubwürdigkeit
vorgenommen wurden, was ich bisher gesagt habe,
ist, dass wir selbst in diesem Stadium
eine Anerkennung des
gemeinsamen repräsentativen Charakters zweier
Verpflichtungen als implizit verstehen können  In der
praktischen Anerkennung ihrer
materiellen Inkompatibilität wird diese rein
formale Dimension des praktischen
Repräsentationsgehalts
durch eine weitere reichere Dimension ergänzt, die sich
erst auf der nächsten Stufe in der Erfahrung
des Irrtums zur Anerkennung der
Inkompatibilität herausstellt, nämlich des Vorhandenseins
des einen oder anderen Fehlers unter den
Verpflichtungen werden als m  auf deren Unvereinbarkeit
zumindest einige dieser Verpflichtungen revidiert
werden müssen, besteht die zweite Stufe der Berichtigung der Fehlererfahrung darin, das zu tun,
wozu man sich in der ersten Stufe
zu seiner praktischen Verpflichtung bekennt, nämlich
die anerkannte
Unvereinbarkeit durch Revidierung oder Zurückweisung
einiger Verpflichtungen zu beheben  der
beugenden Verpflichtungen in dem Beispiel,
indem sie die Überzeugung des gebogenen Stocks aufgeben und die Überzeugung des geraden Stocks beibehalten,
behandelt das Subjekt die erste Gegenwartspräsentation
als eine bloße
Erscheinung und die zweite präsentiert
die entsprechende Realität für in diesem
Stadium der Erfahrung des Irrtums
fehler lokalisiert und
identifiziert das problem das thema nimmt
es ist der verkrümmte stab verpflichtung es ist ein
fehler abzulehnen es ist praktisch
es nicht auszudrücken wie die dinge wirklich sind
denn einen richter über den inhalt zu befürworten
muss man tun um dabei zu sein
oder es in der Praxis so zu behandeln, dass es
ausdrückt, wie die Dinge wirklich
sind  Das Subjekt hatte
diesen Status zuvor praktisch dem Urteil des gebogenen Stocks zuerkannt, indem es
ablehnte, dass eine frühere
Verpflichtung es nicht mehr
verdient, dass das Subjekt
es als durch seine Kollision
mit anderen Verpflichtungen offenbart betrachtet, weil es lediglich
vorgibt, auszudrücken, wie die Dinge wirklich
sind  ist eine bloße Erscheinung,
außerdem stellt der Triangulationspunkt
sicher, dass das zurückgewiesene Urteil des gebogenen Stocks
praktisch nicht
nur als eine Erscheinung, sondern als eine
Erscheinung der Realität interpretiert wird,
die durch die beibehaltene Verpflichtung präsentiert wird, was
den Stock als
wirklich gerade herausgestellt hat  Die Erfahrung des
Irrtums
Sowohl die Verpflichtungen des geraden Stocks als auch die des gebogenen
Stocks werden praktisch
als Darstellungsweisen einer Realität genommen oder behandelt, wobei
der Stock eine vertikale
Darstellung und eine falsche Darstellung
dieser beiden Phasen des Prozesses darstellt, der
die Erfahrung des Irrtums ist, dessen
Eingeständnis  Unvereinbarkeit und
deren Behebung beitragen
die Erfüllung der Darstellungsweise
Bedingung an eine Konstruktion von intentionalen
Gehalten für die Funktionsweise von Urteilen,
ihre Rolle in diesen Phasen
der Fehlererfahrung zeigen, was
man tun muss, um damit
praktisch als Anerkennung der
Repräsentationsdimension zu gelten  von konzeptionellem
Gehalt zeigen sie, was es bedeutet, Urteile in der Praxis so zu nehmen oder zu behandeln, dass
sie X' repräsentieren
oder den Anschein erwecken, wie etwas Repräsentiertes
wirklich ist
Zustandsglaube in der
zweiten Phase wird die Autorität des
geraden Stockglaubens gut unterstützt
, die des gebogenen Stockglaubens wird
im Zusammenhang mit kollateralen
Überzeugungen bezüglich Starrheit abgelehnt,
was die Form starrer Objekte und
die relative Zuverlässigkeit der visuellen
Wahrnehmung unter verschiedenen Bedingungen verändern kann  Der
gerade Stockglaube wird als
Maßstab für die Beurteilung des
Richtigen akzeptiert  Da die Urteilskraft des
gebeugten Glaubens nicht
vereinbar ist, wird letzterer
nach diesem Standard als falsch abgelehnt. Der
gebeugte Stock-Glaube wird als
verantwortlich für die Konstellation von
Verpflichtungen bewertet, die den geradlinigen
Stock-Glauben einschließt
Wie im
Urteil des geraden Stocks dargestellt
, erfüllt der gerade Stock das normative funktionale
Amt, das für die Realität charakteristisch ist, die
von einigen repräsentiert
wird, die praktisch als seiend behandelt werden,
dh er ist für das Bewusstsein ein
maßgeblicher Standard für
Bewertungen der Richtigkeit der Darstellung dieses
Zählers als seiend  darüber, weil
sie ihr gegenüber für solche
Einschätzungen verantwortlich sind, so sehen wir, wenn wir uns die Rolle ansehen,
die verschiedene Bindungen in der
Erfahrung von Fehlern spielen, dass die
Bedingung des Darstellungsmodus
in dem Sinne erfüllt ist, wie es die normative
Auslegung des Darstellens erfordert
die rationale Nebenbedingung ist
ebenfalls erfüllt  indem sie
repräsentative Bedeutung funktional im
Hinblick auf die Rolle verstehen, die begrifflich
artikulierte inhaltliche Richter in
Prozessen spielen, die die Struktur der
Fehlererfahrung haben, denn im
Kontext der Konstellation von
Sicherheitenverpflichtungen in unserem Beispiel liefert die gerade
Stick-Glaube einen Grund für die
Ablehnung  Der Glaube an den gebogenen Stock, dass
die Kollision zwischen den beiden
rational gelöst ist, der Glaube an die
unterschiedliche Zuverlässigkeit der visuellen
Wahrnehmung unter den Bedingungen, die
zur Billigung des gebogenen Stocks und
des geraden Stocks geführt haben
Stock Glaube an die
Erfahrung des Irrtums unser Subjekt in der
Praxis behandelt die Realität der gerade
Stock als rationaler Zwang
zur Beurteilung verschiedener Erscheinungen, da er
auf diese Weise politisch vorgeht.
In der Praxis nimmt oder behandelt das Subjekt den
gebogenen Stock Glaube als Ausdruck dessen,
wofür die Dinge sind  C  Bewusstsein und
der gerade Stockglaube drücken aus,
was die Dinge an sich sind, und diese
Zustände wiederum sind das, was die
Überzeugungen für das Bewusstsein praktisch oder
implizit sind, denn das Subjekt der
Erfahrung des Irrtums muss das natürliche
Bewusstsein nicht explizit mit
Konzepten von Realität und Erscheinung
repräsentieren und repräsentieren  was die
Dinge an sich sind und was
für Bewusstseinsnomina und -phänomene
, damit sie
eine der kontextuell materiell
unvereinbaren Ernährungsweisen der
Commitment-Diät der Verpflichtungen beibehalten und die andere ablehnen,
um verständlich zu sein, als praktisch zu nehmen oder zu
behandeln, als zu präsentieren, wie  die dinge
wirklich sind und die andere
nur den schein darstellt, das eine ist für das bewußtsein,
was der stab an sich gerade ist und
der andere für das bewußtsein, was der
stab nur für das bewußtsein ist oder war
, das meint hegel, wenn er sagt,
daß das bewußtsein sich selbst
verschafft  sein eigenes Standard-Zitat
wie  zitiere in dem, was das Bewußtsein
in sich selbst als das Ansich
für das Wahre bezeichnet, haben wir den Maßstab, an dem
das Bewußtsein selbst
sein Wissen zu messen vorschlägt Ende des Zitats
nach Hegels Modell der begriffliche Gehalt,
den darstellende und vertretene
Erscheinung in Wirklichkeit Phänomen und
Noumenon teilen  Verpflichtung
und abstrahiert von den beiden unterschiedlichen
Formen, die Beziehungen materieller
Inkompatibilität und Konsequenz annehmen können,
die subjektive Form, die durch
dejan explizit gemacht wird, nehmen normatives Vokabular und die
objektive Form, die durch alle dicken modalen Vokabular explizit gemacht wird,
konzeptueller
Inhalt ist im Wesentlichen und nicht nur
zufällig das, was annehmen kann  diese beiden
Formen Das zentrale metaphysische Konzept
, das diesen Punkt beinhaltet und ausdrückt
, ist Hegels Konzept der bestimmten
Negation. Es artikuliert den Sinn, in
dem alles, was Gedanken oder
Tatsachen sind, als bestimmte Inhalte gelten kann
, indem es einen starken Kontrast
zum Ausschluss anderer
Determinanten bildet  Denken Sie daran, dass Spinoza
Obdachlose auf tos Nagato bestimmen. Auf der objektiven
Seite bedeutet dies, dass das Wie der Dinge im
Wesentlichen auch eine Frage der
Struktur seiner Aletha-Modalbeziehungen ist
, was es unmöglich macht und was es
notwendig macht. Auf der subjektiven
Seite bedeutet es, dass Verpflichtungen sein können
nur im
Zusammenhang mit der funktionalen Rolle verstanden werden, die sie
im Prozess des Erwerbs und der Überarbeitung von
Verpflichtungen spielen, denn es ist dieser Prozess, der
von den deontischen normativen
Beziehungen von Inkompatibilität und
Konsequenz bestimmt wird, die die
konzeptuellen Inhalte dieser Verpflichtungen artikulieren,
eines der Dinge, die immer sind
schwer nachzuvollziehen war über Hegels Begriff
der Negation bestimmte Negation und damit
seine Konzeption von Begriffen und deren
Inhalten gerade seine Verbindung
jener traditionellen logischen Begriffe mit
dynamischen Kategorien von Bewegungsabläufen
Unruhe, dahinter steckt diese
Verbindung von Inkompatibilität
im normativen Sinne und  der Profi
Hegel betrachtet die subjektive
Artikulation des konzeptuellen Inhalts
von Verpflichtungen durch Tag auf normative
Beziehungen materieller Unvereinbarkeit
und Konsequenz und das Objekt der
Artikulation des konzeptuellen Inhalts
von Verpflichtungen durch Aletha modale Beziehungen
von Material
in Kompatibilität und Konsequenz  als zwei
seiten einer münze zwei aspekte einer
konzeption ist sein inhaltlicher anspruch, dass
seine konzepte der bestimmten negation und des
konzeptuellen inhalts nicht zweideutig sind,
sondern eine feine struktur haben, die sich
durch die beziehungen zwischen den
beiden eng miteinander verbundenen formen subjektiv
und objektiv der konzeptuellen inhalte artikuliert
definiert durch determinierte Negation und
Mediation kann dieser Anspruch eine
zentrale Rolle einnehmen in seiner Strategie
, die subjektiven und
objektiven Seiten des
intentionalen Erkenntniszusammenhangs zu verstehen, indem er sie als
komplementäre Aspekte konzeptueller
Gehalte abstrahiert, einer Strategie, der er bereits
entgegensetzt  Einführung in traditionelle
Ansätze, die versuchen,
vorausgehend und unabhängig voneinander spezifizierte
Konzepte von Subjekt und Objekt zu nehmen und sie
irgendwie zusammenzufügen, um ein
verständliches Bild ihrer
beabsichtigten Beziehungen zu erhalten, dieser Ansatz ist seiner Meinung nach dem
Untergang geweiht, solange eine
psychologische Konzeption des
Konzeptuellen und damit des  verständlich
schränkt konzeptuellen Inhalt auf die
subjektive Seite dessen ein, was dann
unweigerlich als eine Kluft der Verständlichkeit erscheint
, die wissende und handelnde Subjekte
von der objektiven Welt trennt, von der sie wissen
und in der sie handeln, aber wie sollen
wir die Konzeption von konzeptuellen Inhalten verstehen, die
durch Beziehungen von artikuliert werden?
Determinanten Negation und Mediation als
amphibisch zwischen ihren beiden Formen
subjektiv normativ und objektiv modal
Diese Frage trifft offensichtlich den
Kern unseres Verständnisses von Hegels
Idealismus. Ich denke, es sollte
im Sinne von zwei Behauptungen verstanden werden
für ein sehr dickes
Modalvokabular Zweitens
gibt es eine Art
Sinnabhängigkeitsverhältnis zwischen diesen
Vokabularen zum ersten Punkt deontisch
normatives Vokabular Sagen wir, was
man tun muss, um damit zu
sagen, was für ein dickes Modalvokabular
wir einmal wollen  was man tun
muss, um als Erfassen der Inhalte zu gelten,
die durch ein dickes modales Vokabular von Li ausgedrückt werden,
indem behauptet wird, dass es unmöglich ist, dass
sowohl P als auch Q oder dass, wenn P, dann
notwendigerweise R in der Praxis
Rückzugsverpflichtungen gegenüber P und Q als
normativ eingeht  inkompatibel und die Verpflichtung
gegenüber P bedeutet normativ eine Verpflichtung
zu unserem Es. Nur wenn man weiß, wie man
mit den Normen übereinstimmt, die am Tag ausgedrückt werden
, kann man zählen, was man zählen kann,
ist in der Lage, modales Vokabular zu verstehen und anzuwenden,
indem man seine Verpflichtungen praktisch so behandelt, als ob sie in diesen
normativen Beziehungen stehen  einander bedeutet
, sie implizit als
Verpflichtungen bezüglich dessen zu verstehen, was
objektiv unmöglich und notwendig ist  Das bedeutet
, sie als
Erscheinungen einer Realität zu verstehen, die von einem solchen Li artikuliert wird,
dass modale Beziehungen, wie wir sie
gesehen haben, sich auf die Erfahrung von Fehlern
einlassen, die von praktischen Normen bestimmt werden, die
deontische Beziehungen der Inkompatibilität respektieren,
was es bedeutet, die eigenen
Verpflichtungen als Erscheinungen zu betrachten oder zu behandeln, die
z repräsentieren  ' einer repräsentierten Realität besteht
in dem deontischen normativen Vokabular, das auf
diese Weise die expressive
Rolle eines pragmatischen Meta-Vokabulars für
alles dicke modale Vokabular hat, bedeutet, dass
man ein sehr dickes modales Vokabular nicht verstehen
kann, es nicht mit Verständnis einsetzen kann
, wenn man
das normative nicht beherrscht  geregelte
praktiken, die durch dejan explizit gemacht werden nehmen normatives
vokabular dies ist eine behauptung über das
praktische begreifen dessen, was durch
eine li-dicke modalität ausgedrückt wird, ein li-dickes
modalvokabular darüber, was man
können muss, um zu sagen, was es sagt, es ist
keine behauptung, was muss  wahr sein für das,
was man sagt, indem man dieses modale
Vokabular verwendet, um wahr zu sein  die Behauptung
ist nicht, dass, wenn einige Behauptungen,
die im deontischen normativen Vokabular formuliert
werden können, wahr wären, es nicht wahr ist und nicht die
Behauptung impliziert, dass keine modalen Behauptungen wahr wären, wenn einige Konzeptbenutzer
kein normatives Vokabular anwenden könnten
Die Behauptung ist,
dass, wenn man nicht praktisch versteht,
was durch das normative Vokabular gesagt wird, das
heißt, wenn man nicht die Dinge tun kann, die sich
auf die Praktiken einlassen, die im normativen Vokabular spezifizierbar sind,
man nicht
verstehen kann, was durch das modale
Vokabular gesagt wird, das ist die Behauptung, dass
es eine Art von Sinn gibt  Abhängigkeit des
modalen Vokabulars von dem, was durch normatives Vokabular ausgedrückt wird,
keine Art von
Referenzabhängigkeit Die Unterscheidung
zwischen Sinnabhängigkeit und
Referenzabhängigkeit kann
an einem Beispiel deutlich gemacht werden, das
weder mit Normativität noch mit Modalität zu tun hat,
unabhängig davon, ob dies der Fall wäre oder nicht
Eine gute Möglichkeit, über das Konzept der Schönheit nachzudenken,
könnten wir als Reaktion definieren
Ich nenne es Schönheitsstern,
indem ich festlege, dass ein Objekt oder eine
Situation als schöner Stern gilt, nur
für den Fall, dass es unter geeigneten
Umständen eine Reaktion des
Vergnügens in einem geeigneten Subjekt hervorrufen würde, das ihm angemessen
ausgesetzt ist, dann ist die Eigenschaft, ein
schöner Stern zu sein  Sinn, der von
dem der Lust abhängig ist, man kann
das Konzept schöner Stern nicht verstehen, wenn man nicht
versteht, dass das Konzept Vergnügen für den
einen in Begriffen des anderen definiert ist, aber
beachte, dass daraus überhaupt nicht folgt,
dass etwas nicht schöner
Stern sein könnte, wenn nicht etwas darauf reagiert  es
mit Freude auf dieser Definition gab
es Sonnenuntergänge, die schöne Sterne waren,
bevor es ein geeignetes Vergnügen gab,
zwei fähige Responder, und sie wären
immer noch schöne Sterne gewesen, selbst wenn
es nie solche Responder gegeben hätte, denn
es könnte immer noch der Fall sein, aber wenn
es solche gäbe  anwesende Responder würden genauso gerne
antworten oder hätten gerne geantwortet
, wenn
wir ein pla definieren  Netz oder ein Stern als
Supraterraner, nur für den Fall, dass er mehr
als das Doppelte der Erde angehäuft hat, verpflichten wir uns damit nicht
, zu leugnen,
dass ein Planet diese
Eigenschaft in einer möglichen Welt haben könnte, in der
die Erde nicht existierte, je nachdem wie
Ihre angegebenen Eigenschaften können
abhängig von anderen Eigenschaften wahrgenommen werden, da
schöne Sterne auf Vergnügen und Super-
Terraner auf der Eigenschaft stehen,
mindestens die doppelte mathematische Masse der
Erde zu haben, ohne
davon abhängig zu sein, dass etwas eine
Eigenschaft P aufweisen kann, die  sinnabhängig, aber nicht
referenzabhängig von einer Eigenschaft P
prime
In einer Welt, in der nichts die
Eigenschaft P prime aufweist, ist die Anspruchsabhängigkeit
modaler Eigenschaften von normgesteuerten
Aktivitäten des Akzeptierens und Ablehnens von
Verpflichtungen
eher von der Art der Sinnabhängigkeit als von der
Art der Referenzabhängigkeit  Welt wäre immer noch
begrifflich strukturiert im Sinne
von Tatsachen über Gegenstände und
ihre Eigenschaften und re  Beziehungen
artikuliert durch starke modale
Beziehungen relativ ruhiger Möglichkeit
und sogar in Welten, die
niemals wissende und handelnde
Subjekte beinhalteten, die normativ
artikulierte Konzepte anwendeten
, um Verpflichtungen einzugehen und abzulehnen, die geistige
Abhängigkeit von der objektiven Welt
, die von dieser Dimension von Hegels
Idealismus behauptet wird  Nennen Sie es objektiven
Idealismus ist nicht die anstößige
Berkeley-Art in Referenzabhängigkeit,
Kant nannte es subjektiven Idealismus, aber
wenn die viel plausiblere oder zumindest
färbbare Art der Sinnabhängigkeit, können wir
mögliche subjektlose Welten verstehen und beschreiben,
auf die normatives
Vokabular als dennoch
anwendbare Gasse zutrifft  dickes modales Vokabular,
aber unsere Fähigkeit, solchen Möglichkeiten einen Sinn zu geben,
hängt davon ab, dass wir in der Lage sind
, uns auf Praktiken
einzulassen, die durch die Anwendung des deontischen normativen Vokabulars explizit gemacht werden,
der Art von Modell
, die Hegel konstruiert, um
zweistufigen Repräsentationsmodellen gegenüberzustehen
Die Verpflichtung zu einem starken Unterschied der
Verständlichkeit zwischen der Repräsentation von x'
und Repräsentanten
hängt von einer Darstellung der konzeptuellen
Inhaltsfülle ab, die dem
amphibischen Nosov-Konzeptgehalt
zwischen einer subjektiven Form, die durch
deontische normative Beziehungen von
Inkompatibilitätsfolge artikuliert wird,
und einer objektiven Form,
die durch Ali-Thicke-Modalbeziehungen artikuliert wird, verpflichtet ist
von Inkompatibilität und
Konsequenz ist die
Korrespondenzbeziehung zwischen ihnen die einer
pragmatischen Metapher Cabul arey,
die eine Art praktischer
Sinnabhängigkeit nach diesem Modell hervorruft modaler
Realismus bringt konzeptuellen Realismus
mit sich, der objektiven Idealismus mit sich bringt Ich beendete
meinen ersten Vortrag mit einer Diskussion über
die  zwei formen des konzeptuellen inhalts die
zwei formen, die der konzeptuelle inhalt
annehmen kann, sobald wir Hegels nicht-
psychologische konzeption davon annehmen, wie
sie durch beziehungen materieller
inkompatibilität und konsequenz artikuliert wird, nämlich
die subjektive und die objektive form, es ist
diese konzeption th  Dies soll
es uns ermöglichen, zu vermeiden, eine
Kluft der Verständlichkeit zwischen Wissendem
und bekannter Erscheinung in der Realität,
die x' und Repräsentanten
in unserer Semantik repräsentiert, auszuheben, eine Kluft, die dann
unweigerlich zu Skepsis in unserer
Erkenntnistheorie führen muss, zu der wir jetzt in der Lage sind
Verstehen Sie die Beziehung zwischen
propositionalen Verpflichtungen, Urteilen,
Überzeugungen, Gedanken, die durch
normative deontische Beziehungen der
Inkompatibilität auf der subjektiven Seite
der Gewissheit artikuliert werden, was Dinge für das
Bewusstsein sind, und Fakten und möglichen
Sachverhalten, die von Allie Thick modal artikuliert werden,
Beziehungen der Unvereinbarkeit
auf der objektiven Seite der Wahrheit, was
Dinge  an sich sind wir jetzt in der
Lage, diese Relation selbst als repräsentational zu verstehen, es geht
darum, x' und repräsentiert x' zu repräsentieren,
weil wir sehen können, wie unsere Verpflichtungen
als Erscheinungen einer
objektiven Realität verständlich
sind, dass diese Verständlichkeit funktionalistisch und pragmatisch ist  Jetzt wissen wir
, was wir in der Reihenfolge tun müssen  Dadurch
nehmen oder behandeln wir unsere Verpflichtungen implizit praktisch
als Erscheinungen einer Realität,
so dass die Unterscheidung zwischen dem, was die
Dinge für das Bewusstsein sind, und dem, was
sie an sich sind, etwas für
das Bewusstsein ist
des Irrtums
operationalisiert das, was ich in meiner ersten Vorlesung
die Verständlichkeit des Irrtums
und das echte Wissen genannt habe, Kriterien
epistemologischer Angemessenheit auf semantische
Erklärungen von intentionaler Inhaltsfülle
und Aboutness. Diese ganze Vorlesung
war eine ausführliche Diskussion darüber, wie
in denselben Begriffen die Art und Weise der Präsentation
bedingt ist  zufrieden sein kann, wie
man die repräsentative
Dimension der Intentionalität in Bezug auf
die expressive konzeptionelle Dimension versteht. Ich
habe diesen Vortrag abgeschlossen, indem ich darüber gesprochen habe,
wie diese erste Dimension und damit die
zweite in Bezug auf das, was man tut, verstanden werden kann, wenn man
sich der
Erfahrung dessen unterzieht  Fehler, das ist, ich habe
talki  ng darüber, wie die Aktivität wissender Subjekte
, die in deontisch-
normativen Begriffen von Verpflichtung und
Anspruch diskutiert wird, und der subjektive Aspekt
des Begriffs der materiellen Inkompatibilität, den
sie artikulieren, als
repräsentativer Inhalt
verstanden werden kann, der als Erscheinung verstanden wird, was
Dinge für das Bewusstsein der Realität sind,
was  Dinge sind an sich
konstituiert durch die objektiven
Sachverhalte, die in einem gleichsinnigen
Sinne von Notwendigkeit und Möglichkeit diskutiert werden, und
den objektiven Aspekt des Begriffs der
materiellen Unvereinbarkeit, den sie
artikulieren, was ich im ersten Vortrag
die rationale Zwangsbedingung genannt habe,
ist die Anforderung, dass
das Dargestellte als
Begründung für Beurteilungen der
Korrektheit der Darstellung von x nachvollziehbar sein,
zeigt sich hier als Folge der
normativen Kontrolle der Darstellung, die
Hegel bereits von Kant
im Rahmen der
hier angebotenen Darstellung des Darstellungsgehalts in
Begriffen eingeführt sieht  der funktionalen Rolle in
durch Fehlererfahrung geprägten kognitiven Prozessen
lässt sich erkennen, wie die
wechselseitige Sinnabhängigkeit der
subjektiven und objektiven Dimensionen
des Metabegriffs der materiellen
Inkompatibilität, der determinierten
Negation, von Tag zu Tag ein
normatives Vokabular übernimmt, das als
pragmatisches Metavokabular dient  Alle thyng Modalvokabular
artikuliert einen tiefen Zusammenhang zwischen der
Befriedigung der Darstellungsweise
und Bedingung und der Befriedigung der
rationalen Zwangsbedingung. Im
nächsten Vortrag werde ich Hegels
Konzeption, wie unser Verständnis
des Wahrheitsbegriffs von der
praktischen Erfahrung abhängt, weiter verfolgen  Fehler und ich werde
am Ende der Einführung detaillierte Lesungen einiger der rätselhaftesten Passagen anbieten,
danke